Democrats vote to establish impeachment
ground rules we may have learned the
identity of the original whistleblower
and Nancy Pelosi comes out in strong
defense of Katie Hill I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn comm slash Penn okay
so yesterday impeachment got real
because Democrats finally voted on
procedures for impeachment now
Republicans had been saying for a while
that all of this was illegitimate
because Democrats had not held an
official vote on whether there ought to
be an impeachment inquiry basically
Nancy Pelosi had gone out there and said
impeachment inquiry declared that has no
legal status there's no legal effect
she's the Speaker of the House but she
is saying a thing it's the equivalent of
Michael Scott declaring bankruptcy in
the office by standing in the middle of
the office and shouting I declare
bankruptcy so Republicans kept saying
well you've established no procedures
the procedures that you haven't
established are obviously bad for us all
of this stuff is being hidden behind
closed doors so how are we supposed to
take any of this seriously well the
Democrats were holding off from
officially declaring an impeachment
inquiry and setting the ground rules
because they didn't really know where
this was gonna go originally all of this
was expected to be quick and dirty
originally the Democrats said that
within a month like by Halloween they
were already gonna be voting on
impeachment why because they felt like
the transcript of the call was going to
be the nail upon which they hung the
impeachment and then that was gonna be
it right they were just gonna move
forward it was gonna be completely
partisan they were just going to do
their interviews behind closed doors
vote for impeachment done and then the
Senate presumably acquit the President
and we'd all move on to the election
well as they have dug into this they
actually think they have something here
this is what this vote betrays the
Democrats actually believe that they now
have enough material to at least damage
president Trump and let's be straight
about this in order for Republicans in
the Senate to votes to actually convict
the President and remove him from office
it's gonna take a lot more than what
Democrats have right now again the
entire allegation against President
Trump relies on his intent on his intent
level was he intending to militarize a
foreign government by using taxpayer
dollars as leverage to get them
specifically to target an American
citizen Joe Biden for political purposes
not as part of a broader anti-corruption
rubric not as part of a broader 2016
investigation not as part of a broader
anti-ukrainian agenda as part of a I
want Joe Biden to go to jail in a
foreign country thing and so I'm
withholding American taxpayer dollars so
that the Ukrainians will go get
Joe and hunter Biden right that's always
been the question and the transcript
didn't clear that up
none of the testimony so far has cleared
that up I've been saying this for weeks
now probably months at this point the
fact is that unless Trump testifies or
Rudy Giuliani testifies those are the
only two people who really know what the
president's intent was in all of this
because the president's intent let's
just say it's a skittish thing it tends
to move around a lot president Trump is
not a guy who plans one one year in
advance what he's going to say he
doesn't plan five seconds in advance
what he's going to say he is a bundle of
sort of reactions and so I've been
saying the whole time I think that this
whole phone call with the Ukrainians his
whole Ukrainian policy here is basically
just a reaction to Rudy Giuliani telling
him things made the person at fault here
yes the president for not actively for
actively failing to recognize what Rudy
Giuliani was doing yes the president
should have should have not taken
Giuliani so seriously but Giuliani was
the one who's feeding all this
information to Trump Trump was taking
all of that wrapping it up in his mind
with Ukrainian corruption and then
talking to Ukrainians about it in the
same way because he does this with
everything he has with every single
topic every topic the president of the
United States has sort of this file card
rightly almost just just just had a note
card a 3x5 that has like a few ideas on
it and he just spits them out if you
give him the topic so you say global
warming and he'll go Chinese hoax spend
too much money like it's just a bunch of
ideas that come in response to a
stimulus and the same thing happens with
regard to Ukraine
somebody says Ukraine to him and the
first thing that he thinks is Ukraine
2016 Hillary Clinton Joe Biden Purisima
like it's it's not that he is thinking
this thing I thought right this has been
my entire contention now does that mean
he did something smart here no doesn't
mean that he did something that a
president should do no doesn't mean that
this impeachable also no that's been my
case in defense of President Trump whoa
Democrats believe they've got enough
politically damaging material on Trump
then now they're gonna move forward with
a formal impeachment inquiry and call
the Republican Bluff to the extent that
they have now fully voted on at least
opening the impeachment inquiry we'll
get to all of that in just one second
first the fact is that if you run a
business hiring can be pretty
challenging here at the daily where we
hire on a regular basis we're constantly
trying to upgrade our staff make our
staff better all of my employees back in
Los Angeles our dress
the day when I arrived back in town and
suddenly I can keep an eagle eye on them
because I use zip recruit calm to make
our business better
here at Daily wire and it's not just is
not just daily wire using zip recruiter
quotable co-founder Gretchen Keebler
needed to hire a game artist for her
education tech company
she knew it wouldn't be easy to find
someone to grow with her team so she
went to zip recruiter because zipper
critter doesn't depend on candidates
finding you it finds them for you it's
technology identifies people with the
right experience and then invites them
to apply to your job so you get
qualified candidates fast
Gretchen posted her job on zip recruiter
and she was quickly finding applicants
the same thing has happened for us here
at Daily wire with results like that
it's no wonder that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the very
first day see why zip recruiter is
effective for businesses of all sizes
try zip recruiter for free and our web
address zip recruiter home slash at
daily wire that is zip recruiter dot-com
/ Dai ly wir a zip recruiter comm slash
at daly wire zip recruiters indeed the
smartest way to hire ok so last night
the House passed an impeachment
resolution along basic partisan lines
only two Democrats voted against only
one Republican voted in favor that would
be Justin Amash who has recently
registered as an independent according
to The Wall Street Journal the House
passed a resolution almost entirely
along party lines to initiate the public
phase of an inquiry into president
Trump's dealings with Ukraine setting a
blueprint for the fourth presidential
impeachment investigation in American
history the 232 to 196 vote underscored
the sharp partisan divide in Washington
over impeachment all Democrats but too
supported the measure all Republicans
rejected the independent a mass used to
be Republican voted YES on the measure
though the move according to The Wall
Street Journal will make the
investigation more public including the
likelihood of televised hearings no
timeframe was given for when that will
happen
the resolution authorizes the House
Intelligence Committee to release
transcripts from past closed-door
interviews with witnesses and gives more
power to Republicans including the right
to call their own witnesses though those
subjects are those requests are subject
to approval by Democrats so in reality
this thing is still going to be kept
largely behind closed doors it's still
going to be handled by the majority
yeah this is not a shock Republicans who
are acting outraged at the fact that the
Democrats are going to veto witness
requests and subpoena requests from
Republicans that's sort of how this
works
the majority does have the power to do
that as a general rule with that said
once this moves into the Judiciary
Committee it becomes incredibly public
so the basic democratic plan is have
shift who is a partisan hack of the
highest order right the guy who is
spending every five seconds in the in on
the CNN cameras talking about the Muller
report was definitely gonna take down
Trump he had set up an actual pup tent
outside the greenroom at CNN he just
spends his days over there like he'd
bring a thermos and a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich and just wait for the
producers at CNN to call him up and then
you just walk one foot into the CNN
studios into a hit well now Adam Schiff
is gonna be running this thing yes it
will still be behind closed doors they
have the author or the authority to
release transcript from past closed-door
interviews but that authority does not
necessarily have to be exercised House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi said ahead of the
vote if we don't have a system of checks
and balances we might as well just elect
a president and go home she waived way
GOP complaints saying these rules are
fairer than anything that has gone
before in terms of an impeachment
proceeding the two Democrats who opposed
the measure were representatives Jeff
Andrew of New Jersey and Colin Peterson
of Minnesota both of them are in Trump
districts circa 2016 Republicans have
said that this this investigation is
still a sham that the procedures are
still unfair House Republicans campaign
are sent moving boxes to about 20
vulnerable Democrats offices trying to
suggest that all of these swing
Democrats are in serious trouble
Democrats are buoyed by polling however
that shows growing support for at least
the impeachment inquiry so most
Americans believe the impeachment
inquiry should move forward very few
actually believe that there's enough
evidence to go after Trump and impeach
him now which is probably why the
Democrats are looking for the televised
House hearings right what they are
trying to do is build momentum for the
impeachment itself because what they've
done is they've pried open the door
where Americans say well we'd like to
hear more but what you've got now is
insufficient so Democrats are saying
well how'd you like if we just spilled
it all out in public this is a
demonstration of a certain level of
confidence by Nancy Pelosi and the
Democrats there's no question about that
the resolution passed on Thursday
according to The Wall Street Journal
will allow President Trump and his
counsel to attend all Judiciary
Committee hearings cross-examine
witnesses and make closing presentations
Republicans in the White House
criticized the resolution because it
doesn't give the president these rights
while the investing
investigation is run by the Intelligence
Committee as it currently is Democrats
say this is still because this is early
where our information gathering stage
now here's the problem once you say that
you've opened the impeachment inquiry
then it's hard to say that you are still
in the information gathering stage
meaning you can initiate any
investigation at any time in the House
of Representatives you don't have to
officially open an impeachment inquiry
in order to do all of that
once you officially open the impeachment
inquiry then it's pretty obvious what
you're talking about now now you're
talking about impeachment you're not
just talking about investigating a phone
call you're not just talking about
investigating I guess a potential crime
although nobody has been able to point
to the statute the Trump allegedly
violated here so the question becomes
whether this is really silly sham
process Republicans were complaining it
was being done by the Intel committee
behind closed doors it's still being
done by the Intel committee behind
closed doors but now Democrats are
saying openly we'll push it over to the
Judiciary Committee at that point it
becomes public at that point Trump can
have a representative question the
witnesses but if you're the Judiciary
Committee you don't have to call anybody
you don't want to call so it's still
pretty unfair to President Trump it's
still pretty unfair to Republicans again
this there are consequences to losing
the House of Representatives as it turns
out White House spokeswoman is Stephanie
Grisham slammed Democrats after the vote
accusing them of engaging in a blatantly
partisan attempt to destroy the
president which is true I mean two
things can be true at once one Democrats
are partisan hacks who want to destroy
the president two there can be some open
questions that probably should be asked
about Trump's behavior with Ukraine the
problem is that it's very difficult for
the it's gonna be difficult for the
American people to separate those two
things and frankly I'm not sure that
they should I mean it is pretty obvious
that the Democrats have wanted to
impeach Trump since the day that he was
elected and they continue to want to
impeach Trump and so when they stand
there and say were just here defunding
the Constitution the American public is
like well are you though or is it just
that you really really really hate Trump
in the private depositions according to
The Wall Street Journal that the house
is already conducted Republicans and
Democrats on the three Committees of
jurisdiction have had equal time to
question witnesses but lawmakers not on
the panels have also been excluded
conducting witness interviews behind
closed doors has been pretty common in
high-profile investigations run by both
Republicans and Democrats
well not impeachment enquiries under GOP
leadership both the Senate and House
intelligence committees conducted
separate reviews of
meddling in the 2016 election they
interviewed witnesses in private but
again there is a difference in kind
between inquiries into particular events
as I say that would make sense
and once you've declared this is about
impeachment at that point we all know
what this whole thing is at that point
we should really be hearing what is
going on behind closed doors so we'll
get some more of that in just one second
first the fact is with the news going
the way it is you are probably looking
at a screen 90% of your waking life
right you're at work and you're looking
at a computer or you're on your phone
scrolling through the news all the time
one of the things that you never think
about is the fact that you could be
getting headaches because of all that it
turns out that staring at screens all
day is not particularly good for your
eyes the average American blast their
eyes with bright screens for up to 11
hours every day whether you are watching
Netflix whether you're on Amazon Prime
or whether you're watching this show or
whether you're just doing your work on
Excel the fact is screen time is not
going anywhere that's that's not going
to change but you can protect your eyes
from it with a pair of Felix gray blue
light filtering glasses they're
available in both non prescription and
prescription they're really really cool
looking Felix Craig glasses filter out
90% of high-energy blue light they
eliminate 99% of glare coming from your
daily barrage of screens and unlike
other blue light filtering glasses
Felix gray uses proprietary blue light
technology embedded into the lens as
opposed to one of those cheap coatings
that tends to scratch or chip over time
like the sunglasses that you bought when
you were 5 years old at the local
fashion Mart Felix where frames are
handcrafted from the same high quality
materials used in high-end designer
frames like organic Italian acetates and
German engineered steel don't go another
day looking at screens without the help
of some Fela craze it can really help
you out go to Felix grey glasses calm
slash Ben for free shipping and 30 days
of risk-free returns or exchanges that's
Felix at gray glasses comm slash Ben
again Felix gray glasses dot-com / Ben
so Republicans are really really angry
about the Democratic vote as well they
should be Nancy Pelosi by the way if you
don't if you think Nancy Pelosi really
wasn't here to do the impeachment she
sort of stumbled into it sure sure
so back in March House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi said that she would only move
forward with Trump's impeachment if the
move received significant bipartisan
support not a single Republican have
voted in favor the New York Times
reported the vote was expected to be
deeply partisan Pelosi claims
historically that she was not for
impeachment this is all the way back in
March right so we're not talking about
ancient
Street here she said impeachment is so
divisive to the country that unless
there's something so compelling and
overwhelming and bipartisan I don't
think we should go down that path
because it divides the country he's just
not worth it well weird because now she
doesn't care anymore very very weird by
the way back in 1998 she said similar
stuff even she was talking with the
Clinton impeachment
she said impeachment is traumatic for
the country you should really only do
this if you have bipartisan support
because to move forward on an
impeachment is very serious I think it
has traumatic impact on the confidence
that the American people have in
government that the world has on our
President and that we are setting a
precedent that we and I believe that we
shouldn't be frivolous in how we go
forward and punishing a president whose
politics we don't approve of well flip
the parties and obviously she flips on
that nearly immediately she then came
out yesterday and she said listen this
is a tragic day for the country oh the
crocodile tears just spilling down her
well Botox cheeks I mean this is
crocodile tears obviously she does
nobody come nobody comes to Congress to
impeach a president really how about
like everyone elected in 2018
half the Democrats campaigned on that
okay the aoc crowd the the squad they've
all been saying for months now every
major Democratic presidential candidate
has said they want Trump impeached
so nobody comes to Congress to impeach a
president that's pretty much the only
reason half the members of the
Democratic caucus came to Congress in
the first place here's Nancy Pelosi just
lying about it this is a sad day it's a
sad day because nobody comes to Congress
to impeach a president of the United
States no one she can't hold back a
smile while she's saying it's a sad day
like it's a sad day because sad I have
I'm so sad about this whole impeachment
thing aren't you sad about it and it
says that she very very sad Nancy Pelosi
and then Adam Schiff does the same
routine Adam Schiff who spent his entire
waking life for the past several years
talking about why President Trump should
not be president why the Moller report
was gonna get him and then if the mother
report wasn't get him get him then
racism was gonna get him and if racism
wasn't gonna get him Ukraine was gonna
get him now you got Adam Schiff also
doing me more in sadness than an anger
routine yeah I'm Adam Shiva I believe
him I think he is totally broken up
about this effort to impeach President
Trump Adam Schiff I don't think he's
been spending every single breath he has
from like 24 hours a day even in his
dreams he does thinking about how he
gets rid of Trump and the
stands on the on the steps of the
Capitol building and talks about what
hero is here's the atom ship pretending
to be very sad about all of us we take
no joy in having to move down this road
and proceed with the impeachment inquiry
but neither do we shrink from it okay
sure you take no joy in and then he goes
back back room and he puts on some queen
and does it happy dance like it's very
obvious what's going on here and this is
why again I don't think that most
Americans truly believe that the
Democrats are doing this in good faith
so they're saying we're willing to hear
it they're taking this hit the American
people are taking the correct attitude
about this they are I know there are a
lot of Republicans who say no the
American people should just rejects all
impeachment inquiry out of out of hand
that's not the job of the American
people the American people should keep
their mind to open to new information
just as they were with the Mullen report
but just as with the Mulla report there
was no support for impeachment there was
no support for getting rid of President
Trump and the American public did not
draw conclusions about Trump rush
inclusion they just said listen we want
to wait and see all the information this
should be the new slogan of the show
right you got Washington Post with it's
nonsense declaration democracy dies in
darkness but the slogan of our show
should be let's wait for the info right
I mean because that's really what I say
half the time is just wait for the
information here let's wait for the
information all I'm saying is that if
you actually believe that Democrats are
not partisan hacks here I don't know
what planet you are living on wait until
you see Eric's wall while doing the same
routine I mean they're just they're just
bad actors right I mean they it's just
bad acting they need to go to the the
Lee Strasberg School of Acting because
they're just bad Eric swallow who spends
who spends all of his time thinking
about nuking gun owning Americans he
lasted in the presidential race for
grand total of 3.7 seconds in which he
completely humiliated himself eric's
wahwah who constantly talks about
getting rid of Trump says this is a very
solemn day it's so solemn the solemnity
of this day I mean my god it's like a
it's like a wedding or a funeral the
solemnity of this day
Erick's while while talking about the
solemnest of the solemn solemn day you
know today there's a solemn day it's one
that none of us you know really look
forward to but you're right we did
afford as we move to this public phase a
process a process for the president as
well as for Republicans I can't control
how they spend their time but it is
time for them to get serious about what
is alleged he's so happy I mean he can
barely hold back the smiles it's it is
hilarious to watch Democrats pretend to
be bipartisan with not a single
Republican supporter it's funny to watch
them act as though they are doing this
not because they hate Trump but because
they just care about the Constitution of
the United States as well see in a
little while the Democrats are not
particularly interested in corruption
they don't care about corruption okay at
the same time they're talking about
impeaching President Trump and all of
this which again open questions on what
Trump did they are out there fulsomely
defending Katie Hill who is stooping
nearly every member of her congressional
staff male and female like they're out
there defending that Nancy Pelosi was
out there defending that so don't give
me you guys are deeply concerned about
corruption when you're out there
defending a member who is under an
ethics investigation and had to resign
because she was under an ethics
investigation and calling it sexist that
she had to resign because she was under
an ethics investigation I'll explain in
just one second first there's something
that you need to know about the use of a
firearm in self-defense real-life
gunfights robberies you know defending
yourself it's not like the movies
roughly 80% of all shots fired in
self-defense will miss their targets
even when fired by trained gun handlers
over 60% of the time the assault victim
is violently ambushed the average attack
only lasts three seconds so what does
that tell us well it means one you have
to have a concrete self-defense place a
self-defense plan in place and number
two you have to practice in number three
you better have some sort of legal
remedy in case you actually do have to
fire a gun in self-defense and that's
exactly why the u.s. CCA was founded
when you join us concealed carry
Association you get instant access to
industry-leading self-defense education
training and legal protection both
thousands of hours of life-saving
resources from the US CCA's
award-winning self-defense team right
there at your fingertips plus they're
giving away 19 free chances to win
$1,000 sort of firearm of your choice
you're a law-abiding citizen who cares
about the Second Amendment you should
own a gun but hurry this offer ends
Thursday October 31st text win two eight
seven two two two right now to learn
more get your 19 free chances at win
text win that's WI n 287 to to to to
claim your entries and learn more win -
eight seven - two - issue join the u.s.
you see any way to do an awful lot of
great stuff go check them out right now
okay so the Democrats who are who are
spending again an enormous amount of
time talking about how
much they hate corruption despise
corruption it's not so true when it's
Katy Hill so Katy Hill does this
Democrat from California who again is
under investigation for ethics
violations it turns out you're not
supposed to the people you're paying
with congressional dollars that's that's
a violation of the house rules well she
had to resign on her way out the door
she ripped shameless Republicans and
gutter operators here is Katie Hill
playing the victim as she made her way
slowly I mean that they had to rip her
out the door she said I'm at the end of
her speech said I'm yielding the rest of
my time but not forever I'll be back no
you want you're done sorry
nobody's nobody's looking forward to
electing you you seem dissolute you seem
as though you can't get your act
together and it seems as though you're
using your your congressional offices as
a sort of personal sexual playground I
don't think that many people are in
favor of that I'm very much amused by
the idea that Katie Hill is being
targeted because she is a because she's
a woman
I'm really amused by this do you believe
that if Katie Hill were a man stooping a
male subordinate and a female
subordinate in his own office that that
person would not be forced to step down
do you really believe that or would this
thing have been so much worse there'll
be no media defenders now there are lots
of media defenders because Katie Hills a
woman and because she is bisexual that
means she's part of the intersectional
hierarchy but if you were a white male
Republican doing the same thing that
with the same people then it would be
look at this piece of crap this piece of
crap has to go like we all know what
this is but the Democrats are out
defending your hair here is Katie Hill
yesterday announcing that this is all
about
shameless Republicans and gutter
operators weird the house is controlled
by Democrats right now so if you wished
to stick around
you could you could try your luck it
seems to me that probably you were
getting some pressure not from
Republicans to step down but from
Democrats here's Katie Hill I'm leaving
because I didn't want to be peddled by
papers and blogs and websites used by
shameless operatives for the dirtiest
gutter politics that I've ever seen and
the right-wing media to drive cliques
and expand their audience by
distributing intimate photos of me taken
without my knowledge let alone my
consent for the sexual entertainment of
millions okay well I don't know when
those voters were taken according to
media reports some of the photos she
posted along with her husband online so
that's a her problem I mean if those
media reports are true that is a her
problem that is not
- bread state that is not the fault of
the UK Daily Mail that is her problem
also her problem don't f your staffers
okay like oh you lady bad idea bad idea
to do this it's a violation of
congressional ethics and yes if you were
a man it would be much worse for you now
like a little worse much worse for you
okay but Nancy Pelosi was out there
defending Katie Hill don't tell me the
Democrats are deeply they're deeply
committed to fighting corruption in
every aspect of American life except
when a congressional ected
congressperson is stooping half her
staff and paying them at the same time
then Nancy Pelosi same Nancy Pelosi is
like more in sadness than inane it's not
partisan we're not going after Trump for
partisan reasons in fact were sad to do
it today but this Katie hill she's a
delight and I wish you would remains as
Nancy Pelosi Katie Hill's decision to
sit to resign is her decision to resign
it is a she's an absolutely outstanding
young public servant very smart
strategic patriotic loves our country
respected by her colleagues in the
Congress for the work that she does here
she made her decision and her timing and
I respect that
mmm is that true is that true I don't
think so I respect her timing she
stepped down I wish you would stick
around sure you do Nancy sure you do
this had nothing to do with you going to
Katie Hill and saying you know lady I
might want to resign it had nothing to
do with Nancy Pelosi forcing her I love
that her well respected by her by her
colleagues especially the ones she's
having sex with I mean like really now
that so when I say that I have trust
issues with the Democrats when it comes
to their honesty on issues like
impeachment
there's a reason I'm saying that by the
way I have trust issues with the media
to the media that wants to root out
corruption they are really angry about
corruption except again when there's an
ethics investigation into a sitting
congresswoman who was apparently
sexually using the help
right I mean like that's that's a wait
until you hear the media's take on Katie
hill leaving versus imagine imagine for
just a second or a president Trump
imagine President Trump were having an
affair I know this is weird with one of
his male staffers and one of his female
staffers well the White House is paying
them think that maybe the media might be
less sympathetic less sympathetic
wait until you hear the media's coverage
of the Katy Hill debacle it's really
amazing first you know one of the things
you want to make sure that your kids
never see are the actual pictures of
Katy Hill that's something that you
don't want your kids to see online
because let's face it they're not
they're not wonderful that's just not
material you want your kids viewing but
your kids are online they're using
screens all the time how can you make
sure that your kids are not seeing stuff
they really shouldn't be seeing guarding
the innocence of your kids you should be
using circle circle helps you set limits
and end the screen time debate with your
kids once and for all
circle is the easiest way to manage your
family's online time all across there
connected devices inside and outside
your home with circle home plus and the
circle app parents can filter what
content is allowed set limits for screen
time and monitor history and usage as
well you can keep track across every
connected device from laptops phones and
tablets to Smart TVs streaming devices
and video game consoles all from one app
every family member has a profile it's
fully customizable to their needs age
and maturity which is great you don't
want your three-year-old treating the
internet the same way or
thirteen-year-old does you'll never stop
worrying about your kids with Circle it
gives you one less thing to worry about
you should be keeping track of what your
kids do online there's just too much bad
material out there right now our
listeners get 30 bucks off of a circle
home plus when you visit meet circle
comm / Ben and enter Ben at checkout get
30 bucks off when you visit meet circle
comm / Ben and again enter Ben a check
out that's meet circle comm / Ben and
enter Ben to save $30 I have young kids
I'm deeply concerned about what their
life is going to be like as they deal
with the online world
I am definitely planning on installing
circle home plus as soon as they are
physically capable of using these
devices on their own because frankly
kids should not be left to their own
devices with these devices okay well as
I say the media reaction to Katie Hill
let's just say it's a little bit
different than the media reaction to the
Trump impeachment so the media reaction
to the Trump aim he was like yeah Trump
has to go Trump definitely did something
very very bad and very very wrong and
then when when it's Katie Hill the media
mourn it and it's because she's a victim
she's a she's a victim you see now I've
said all along since day one of the Katy
Hill debacle that if in fact people were
releasing revenge porn on her they
should go to jail that is a crime in the
state of California it should be a crime
right she is a victim of people who are
doing that to her also she's involved in
pretty severe ethics violations if she
is doing what she is alleged to have
been doing and
was because the material is out there I
mean the pictures are there that is what
it is the media though they're mourning
Katie hill okay he'll again imagine she
were a man for half a second
not even a Republican man imagines you
are a Democrat man all we would get for
weeks on end is toxic masculinity men
are pigs
this is why we need more women in
Congress by the way you know who used to
say that Katie Hill back in 2017 she had
an entire tweet with a list of men who
are sexual who were sexual abusers or
are accused of sexual harassment she
said this is why we need more women in
Congress what to act just like those
dudes I mean like I'm very confused
Katie help in any way in any case the
the the people over the Washington free
beacon put together this super cut of
the media morning at Katie Hill it is
pretty astonishing she did resign say
it's been a difficult week for Katie
Hill this is a pretty shocking turn of
events she was such a star and it's it's
unfortunate because she was around the
first term representative considered a
rising star she was a rising star she
was a rising star the writing star in
the Democratic Party considered a rising
star there's no doubt she was one of the
named ones that we know about for the
big blue waves another tragic a she was
such an up and rising great really what
looked her district that's one red to
blue it's a loss but you know I think
there's a double double standard on the
hill yeah and she was young and gonna be
a face of the party I think the whole
situation is quite unfortunate I don't
feel it was the right move I feel that
there is incredible hypocrisy that goes
on Nancy Pelosi is is is doing the right
thing but it's still something of a
tragedy it really seems like the bad
guys one here it's oversimplify okay so
pretty pretty amazing the bad guys one
here which bad guys which bad guys you
mean Nancy Pelosi you told her to step
down and all likelihood Nancy Pelosi is
trying to backfill that now saying no I
didn't tell her to step down the media
rushing to Katie hills defense let's
just say that they do not have tons of
credibility when it comes to we are the
corruption fighters it seems to me that
your agenda is is pretty clear now with
that said I've been saying all along
they're still open questions about
president Trump's conduct with regard to
Ukraine now there was a piece of
testimony that was that was pushed out
there yesterday and the media jumped all
over it this was the testimony of Tim
Morrison Tim Morrison is a senior White
House official who listens
president Trump's controversial call
with Ukraine's President Vladimir
zalenski according to The Daily Beast
and they were pushing out this testimony
the Democrats were the media were
because they were suggesting that he was
deeply worried about the phone call but
there's one thing that he said in his
testimony that kind of this is the crux
of the matter quote I want to be clear I
was not concerned that anything illegal
was discussed and that the whole thing
in that the whole thing like Trump says
stuff it's uncomfortable all the time
it's called like Trump there's not even
that's what he does I mean watch his
Twitter account if you want to be made
uncomfortable at least once every week
just watch his Twitter account it's not
difficult we all know this this is all
baked into the cake okay no surprises
here the question is did he do something
illegal so now he said two things in his
testimony one of them was widely covered
by the media one not so much and one not
so much was he didn't do anything
illegal the one that was widely covered
is that after the call between zalenski
and Trump took place
Morrison directed that the transcript of
it be put on a secret White House server
he said that the memo the White House
released about the call to the best of
his memory is complete and thorough okay
so that gives the lie to all of the
testimony that was being put out there
that the ellipses and the transcript of
the call revealed the part where Trump
offered to sign a personal check to
Vladimir zolensky if you prosecuted joe
biden personally like that never
happened the call is what the call is
you can interpret it how you want to
interpret it you can read it apparently
president Trump wants to do like a
dramatic reading okay the latest news
that President Trump is so confident in
the perfect phone call that he
apparently wants to read the Ukraine
call transcript to the American people
this is where people around him should
say mr. president like let's not like
they like that bad idea
bad ideas mr. Pres he was a dramatic
reader
according to the Washington Examiner a
defiant president from signals he will
not cooperate with the Democratic
Party's impeachment proceedings
insisting his telephone conversation
with Vladimir zalenski was a good call
that he might read it aloud to Americans
so they can see his points he said in an
interview at the Washington Examiner
this is over a phone call that is a good
call he said at some point I'm gonna sit
down perhaps it's a fireside chat on
live television and I will read the
transcript of the call because people
have to hear it when you read it it's a
straight call bad
idea why is this a bad idea okay first
of all then there will be audio of your
voice reading the very things that you
threatened so let's make how is that you
want to create campaign ads for
Democrats I can't think of a much better
way to do that like when he gets that
line I'm asking you for a favor don't
you think the Democrats are immediately
gonna grab the audio of you saying that
and put it at the lead of every single
ad they run from now till the end of the
election but what in the world but this
is why Republicans should in Congress
and elsewhere do not take your hints on
the defense of the president from the
president he's not a lawyer and where is
he hires so far have been Michael Cohen
who's in jail and Rudy Giuliani who may
go to jail so like just take take take a
break take a valium and think to
yourself what did Trump actually do here
if you want to defend the president if
you want to fend from think like how
would be the best way to do that and the
best way to do that is not please the
baby okay like I have a three-year-old
he always wants to eat sweets I can give
him sweets he's gonna be fat and he'll
die of diabetes like or I could just say
no that's not a good idea when president
Trump's comes to defending himself do
not feed the baby the sweets stop it no
the answer is no and I hope to god
somebody steps in with him and says no
don't do that because again the
Democrats have to prove something right
the Democrats have to prove something
and they have not proved it yet and the
American people don't believe they've
proved it yet the American people are
fine with asking questions they're
always fine with asking questions good
for the American people but Democrats
actually have to prove this stuff okay
so as I say the the media we're trying
to turn Tim Morrison's Connor I mean
this is a perfect example of the media
trying to spin a piece of testimony
that's not actually great for the
Democrats Tim Morrison said a couple of
things and only one of those things only
one of those things actually helps
Democrats the others do not the one that
helps Democrats is the idea that he put
it on a secret White House server but
even that doesn't really help the
Democrats that's been common practice
for years the New York Times already
reported that why has that been common
practice for years maybe because every
single time from says anything against
leaked to the media
so he's been putting it on the secret
server for years like he's been putting
on this confidential sir he couldn't do
that he's the president he can make
things classified he can make things
unclassified and then Morrison said two
other things right he said it wasn't the
illegal behavior he said that the
president did not engage in illegal
behavior and the transcript was complete
none of
cuts in favor of democrats but the
headline of course is that the the
headline from Politico is that this
particular official Morrison confirmed
key testimony linking Trump to quid pro
quo listen we know what happened here
the the White House should stop saying
there was no quid pro quo there was a
quid pro quo the question is whether it
was a corrupt quid pro quo as I have
been saying for weeks quid pro quos in
foreign policy happen all the time you
know it's a quid pro quo Joe Biden
saying explicitly he was going to link
foreign aid to Ukraine to them cleaning
up their act on corruption that's a quid
pro quo is it inappropriate quid pro quo
probably not the question is whether
this is a violation of law in terms of
being bribery or attempt to influence
the election from outside or anything
like that now as I say Republicans are
increasingly suspicious about all of
this mainly because Democrats continue
to make Republicans suspicious about all
of this I'll explain in just one second
first you're gonna have to go over to
Daley wire.com and subscribe $9.99 a
month gets you a subscription to daily
wire when you do you get all sorts of
fantastic goodies including special
access to the daily wire app that app is
here it is really first-rate if you're a
subscriber you can access all of our
content including articles shows and
more straight from the app all access
subscribers get our new exclusive
discussion features where they can
interact directly with our hosts writers
and other special guests the app is
available on Apple and Android
downloaded today become a subscriber
come and join the fun we have all sorts
of goodies for you so please go check
that out right now for 99 bucks a year
obviously as you know you get the
greatest in all beverage vessels it is
magnificent in every conceivable way go
get it go get that by spending ninety
nine bucks a year which is cheaper than
the monthly subscription we're the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so what are the Republican defenses
against all this going to be well first
of all they are going to cite the fact
that this is indeed highly partisan and
they are going to cite to a report that
was made by Paul Sperry yesterday a real
clear investigations talking about who
this whistleblower is according to
Sperry and according to sources inside
various congressional committees Sperry
reports the person is a guy named Erik
charmella and apparently he is an
Associated registered Democrat held over
from the Obama White House he previously
worked with VP Joe Biden he previously
worked with former CIA director John
Brennan and he left his national
security council posting in the White
House's West Wing in mid 2017 amid
concerns about negative leaks to the
media he has since been returned to CIA
headquarters in Langley Virginia
according to a former NSC official
according to Paul Sperry he was accused
of working against Trump and leaking
against Trump also apparently huddled
for guidance with the staff of House
Intelligence Committee Chairman Adam
Schiff so if you are a Republican of
course you have a lot of trust issues
with this particular impeachment inquiry
the whistleblower who apparently created
the thing was a democratic operative who
is working for the National Security
Council and then was booted from the NSC
and back to CIA headquarters the didn't
elect Trump and then he was working with
Adam chef behind closed doors and now
you have Adams Chef leading up an
impeachment inquiry that does not have
proper evidence so that gives
Republicans a few lines of defense
basically the Republican line of defense
is sort of akin but with more evidence
to the Hillary Clinton line of defense
during the Clinton impeachment so she
said there was a vast for right-wing
conspiracy
DeWine on the right is going to be that
this was a democratic put up job from
the very start that everybody knew there
was no illegal activity but they were
going to elevate activity about which
they could rightly be concerned in two
impeachable activity because they were
looking for an excuse to impeach Liz
Cheney who is the third ranking member
of the House on the other Republican
side she said history will hold the
Democrats responsible you saw Democrats
on the floor of the house arguing that
somehow it was Republicans who were
putting politics above national security
there is no one who has done that the
way that Nancy Pelosi and Adam Schiff
have done that history will hold them
accountable history will judge them
we're at a moment where the nation faces
grave significant ongoing threats okay
Kevin McCarthy who is the house
leader he said something very similar he
said look this is obviously not about
what Trump did this is obviously about
an attempt to undo the last election and
when it comes to motives he's right
again two things can be true once
Democrats are badly motivated also there
can be open questions about the Ukraine
thing but what McCarthy says here is
true Democrats are trying to impeach the
president because they are scared they
cannot defeat him at the ballot box
that's not my words that's the words of
my colleagues from the other side of the
aisle that has offered impeachment three
different times this impeachment is not
only an attempt to undo the last
election is it an attempt to influence
the next one as well okay and of course
that is true speaking of attempts to
influence the next election the media
are cheering wildly as Twitter decides
they're going to ban political ads why
do they want to ban political ads the
media because then guess who gets to be
the middleman between the politicians in
you the members of the media they don't
want you to see direct appeals from
politicians they don't want you to see
Trump's actual ad what they want is for
you not to see that ad they don't want
it to pop up in your feed because you
might be convinced by the ad instead
they want you to read their garbage
fact-check of the ad why because it
turns out that Trump's ad campaign is
probably gonna be pretty effective so
during the World Series the Trump
campaign already ran one ad they ran in
ads during the World Series the ad is
actually pretty good
here is the ad that the Trump campaign
ran during the World Series President
Trump is changing Washington creating
six million new jobs 500,000 new
manufacturing jobs cutting illegal
immigration in half obliterating Isis
their Caliphate destroyed their
terrorist leader Ted but the Democrats
would rather focus on impeachment and
phony investigations ignoring the real
issues but that's not stopping Donald
Trump he's no mr. nice guy but sometimes
it takes a Donald
to change Washington I'm Donald Trump
and I approve this message
that's a good at that's a good ad that
is a good strong ad the reason it's a
good ad is because again even the Trump
campaign is like you may not like him
but you need him right you don't like
him but you need him on that wall and
that is Trump's best pitch yeah I'm
gonna say crazy things yeah I'm gonna do
ridiculous stuff but I took out Baghdady
right the economy is really good I'm
standing up to China cuz if he just ran
on his record he'd win
right so the ad campaign is going to be
that so what you're going to see is in
attempt an overt attempt by the members
of the media to actually stop political
advertising why because they know that
if Trump runs an ad they're just gonna
critique the ad and then the only thing
you see is their critique of the ad if
you can't directly access the ad by
going onto Facebook or Twitter that's
why the media are wildly churring they
shut down in core political speech by
twitter twitter yesterday announced that
they were going to not run any political
ads and no ads by politicians and they
said they're gonna do this because they
can't they don't have the resources to
fact-check the ads well they don't have
the resources to fact-checked every
tweet either if they did they'd have to
shut down Twitter so what exactly are
they talking about here what they're
really talking about is shutting down
the ability of campaigns to reach you
they don't want Republican campaigns to
reach you because they know full well
that Democratic campaigns will reach you
through the editorial board of the New
York Times through the shows at CNN
there are two methods of receiving
information one is through the media and
one is directly from politicians Trump
has an uncanny ability to go around the
media and directly address the American
people he does it all the time that's
what his Twitter account is really good
for for him so why he's constantly
talking it up what Democrats thus would
like to do is deprive him of that second
ability so everything has to be filtered
through the prism that the media are
using and that's why they're attacking
mark zuckerberg right that is what
you're seeing over the New York Times
every single day they're trying to
browbeat Mark Zuckerberg into banning
political advertising on Facebook now
what they are neglecting is that at a
certain point this is gonna come back
and bite them - right what happens when
Planned Parenthood wants to run an ad
why is it that a politician should not
be able to run an ad but Planned
Parenthood should be able to run an ad
you're not fact-checking Planned
Parenthood's ad are you so this thing is
going to extend out pretty radically
some of the accusations made against
Zuckerberg are patently ridiculous so
for example yesterday Kara Swisher who's
just a god-awful columnist at the New
York Times
she suggested that Mark Zuckerberg is
allowing political ads on Facebook not
because he doesn't wish to quash free
speech but because he needs the profit
okay the the gross revenue of Facebook
you know how much of a you know how much
of the gross revenue of Facebook is like
direct political ads from campaigns it's
a minut percentage minut minut
percentage now the media were saying
just a second ago that when Facebook was
fined some five billion dollars for
privacy violations the fine wasn't big
enough to affect their behavior I
promise you that Facebook is not making
five billion dollars from political
advertising they're probably not even
making five hundred million
they're probably out making five million
dollars maybe they're making five
million dollars maybe from advertising
it's isn't that profit it's about the
media wants an excuse to shut all this
down so the dumbest column of the day
along these lines comes courtesy of
Aaron Sorkin who frankly sounds like
he's back on the sauce Aaron Sorkin has
a piece today titled an open letter to
Mark Zuckerberg he says mark in 2010 I
wrote the social network and I know you
wish I hadn't you protested that the
film was inaccurate and that Hollywood
didn't understand that some people build
things just for the sake of building
them we do understand that we do it
every day I didn't push back on your
public accusation that the movie was a
lie because I'd had my say in the
theaters but you and I both know that
the screenplay was vetted to within an
inch of its life by a team of studio
lawyers with one client and one goal
don't get sued by Mark Zuckerberg okay
so first of all that's a very different
standard from it's true right not suable
and true are two very different things
right in order for Zuckerberg to sue
you'd have had to defame him it would
have to be a particular standard right
you'd have to be with malice a malicious
attempt to defame Zuckerberg so that's a
pretty high standard that doesn't mean
that the movies true like movie is half
fiction in any case what what Sorkin
then goes on to say is absurd he says I
didn't push back on your public
accusation that the movie was a lie it
was hard not to feel the irony while I
was reading excerpts from your recent
speech at Georgetown University in which
you defended on free speech grounds
Facebook's practice of posting
demonstrable false ads from political
candidates
I admire your belief in free speech I
get a lot of use out of the First
Amendment more important it's a bedrock
of our democracy and it needs to be kept
strong but this can't possibly be the
outcome you and I want to have crazy
lies pumped into the water supply that
corrupts the most important decisions we
make together lies that have a very real
and incredibly dangerous effect on our
election and our lives and our
children's lives
don't say Larry Flynt not even Larry
Flynt would say Larry Flynt this isn't
the same as pornography which people
don't rely upon for information last
year over 40% of Americans say they got
news from Facebook of course the problem
could be solved by those people going to
a different news source or you could
decide to make Facebook a reliable
source of public information
the tagline on the artwork for the
social network read in 2010 you don't
get to 500 million friends without
making a few enemies that number sounds
quaint just nine years later because one
third of the planet uses your website
now and right now on your website is an
ad claiming that Joe Biden gave the
Ukrainian attorney general a billion
dollars not to investigate his son
everywhere every square inch of that is
a lie and it's under your logo well
that's not actually what the what the ad
actually says the ad is a little bit
more oblique than that to be fair to the
ad but with that said Sorkin saying that
he wants to be the fact checker is
patently insane but but everybody on
left wants to be the fact checker
because what they really want is for
Trump now to be able to run that out on
Facebook right that is the goal
it's it Sorkin did this column's an
absurdity he says even after the
screenplay for the social network
satisfied the standards of Sony's legal
department we sent the script as
promised over a handshake to a group of
senior lieutenants at your company and
invited them to give notes after we shot
the movie we arranged a private
screening of an early cut for your chief
operating officer Sheryl Sandberg miss
Sandberg stood up in the middle of the
screening turned to the producers who
were standing in the back of the room
and said how can you do this to a kid
you were 26 years old at the time but
all right I get it I hope your CEO a CEO
walks into your office leans in and says
how can we do this to tens of millions
of kids are we really gonna run an ad
that claims Kamala Harris ran dog fights
out of the basement of a pizza place
while Elizabeth Warren destroyed
evidence that climate change is a hoax
and the deep state sold meth to Rashidah
to leave and Colin Kapernick what in the
world is he even talking about but what
in what in the actual hell is he is he
talking about
the answer is that none of those ads
would ever run why because the blowback
from the ads would be worse than the
effect of the ads themselves obviously
but the greatest check on misinformation
is good information it is not a shutdown
from people who supposedly know better
by the way and Zuckerberg promptly
destroyed I mean like really owned
Sorkin he proceeded to it's pretty
fantastic he proceeded to tweet out in
actual
quote from the American president in
which in which the the main character
waxes philosophic about the First
Amendment
Zuckerberg responded to all of this by
tweeting out quote America isn't easy
America is advanced citizenship you
gotta want it bad because it's gonna put
up a fight it's gonna say you want free
speech let's you acknowledge man whose
words make your blood boil who's
standing center stage and advocating at
the top of his lungs that which you
would spend a lifetime opposing at the
top of yours you want to claim this land
as the land of the free then the symbol
of your country can't just be a flag the
symbol also has to be one of its
citizens exercising his right to burn
that flag in protest show me that defend
that celebrate that in your classrooms
then you can stand up and sing about the
land of the free aaron sorkin the
american president so again what is this
really about this is about the fact that
they want to shut down the the the flow
of information that is the goal to shut
down the flow of information
why are Democrats have focused in on
this because they lost in 2016 and why
are they focused in right now on this
because going into 2020 Democrats are
weak this is why they are doing the
impeachment thing it's also why bill is
still leaving it out there then maybe
Hillary will jump in the race bill was
asked about this in the last 24 hours
and here's Bill Clinton explaining
Hillary may run or she may not run I
don't know no idea I'm the only one
that's not running for anything and ever
or at least like she may or may not ever
run for anything but I can't legally run
for president again she may or may not
run she may or may not by the way my
actual belief is that she will not run I
don't think that she's going to jump
back in she'd be a fool not to by the
way she really should because what does
she have to lose her sterling
credentials here what exactly does she
have to lose her her long history of
losing oh well she lost one more time
like doesn't even hurt her but do I
think I don't think bill has any insight
I don't think they talk to each other I
think that Bill and Hillary haven't
haven't had a face-to-face conversation
in about 15 years but with that said the
fact that the Democrats are still
leaving the door open to that
demonstrates how desperate they are
meanwhile the Democrats are celebrating
because President Trump apparently
announced on Twitter that he was moving
out of New York he tweeted out 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue the White House is
the place I have come to love and will
stay for hopefully another five years as
we make America great again
my family and I will be making Palm
Beach Florida our permanent residence I
cherish New York and the people of New
York and always will but unfortunately
despite the fact that I pay millions of
dollars in city state and local taxes
each year I've been treated
very badly by the political leaders in
both the city and the state few have
been treated worse I hated having to
make this decision but in the end it
will be the best for all concerned as
president I will always be there to help
New York and the great people of New
York it will always have a special place
in my heart this prompted Andrew Cuomo
to tweet out tweet out good riddens it's
not like Donald's front pay taxes here
anyway
he's all yours Florida but I have a
feeling that he paid some taxes in New
York and then Bill DeBlasio said don't
let the door hit you on the way out or
whatever ground cereal groundhog killer
Bill de Blasio has some words obviously
look Trump isn't making the movie
doesn't need to stick around New York
and like why would he stick around New
York or the Attorney General overtly
stated upon her election that she was
out to get him but it does show that the
gap in the country that is now arisen
and it's the reason why any impeachment
inquiry from here on out unless the
evidence is clear and convincing the
American people are just not going to
trust it right now the evidence is not
clear and convincing the Democrats have
not proved themselves to be honest
arbiters of any of this which means they
better come up with the goods or the
American people are not going to back
them in this right now it's not hurting
them because the American people are
withholding judgment but there will come
a point at which Democrats vote on this
thing and if the evidence is just not
strong enough the American people are
going to buck back against them and
that's when you could actually see a bit
of a boost for Trump okay you know
instead of things I like and things I
hate today because it's a Friday I've
decided that we're going back to the
Bible so this is this is something that
we started last week every week the Jews
read a portion of the Old Testament this
week's portion of the Old Testament is
the story of Noah it also happens to
cover the story of the Tower of Babel
and it's really you know it's all
puzzling stuff our Genesis is really
interesting and metaphorical it's got
all sorts of real-world implications
it's really deep deep layered stuff that
is buried in the Western psyche that's
why I talk about the Bible not because
not just because I'm a Bible believer
but because even if you're not a Bible
believer as I say every week now even if
you're not a Bible believer you should
understand the roots of your
civilization and how deeply embedded
these stories are in the psyche of
judeo-christian civilizations in the
West so the parsha which is what we call
a partial means portion the portion of
Genesis that we read is this portion
about Noah and this portion covers
basically three different fundamentally
different ways of viewing the world
so this portion begins with libertinism
the world before Noah is this very
libertine place right the world is
filled with sin that is the quote right
the that the the ways of before all
flesh had corrupted its way upon the
earth the earth had become corrupt
before God the earth had become filled
with robbery this is a libertine society
where everybody could do basically what
they want and the society tears itself
apart right the entire world had become
corrupted in a live and let live world
the person who doesn't actually indulge
it like it becomes you see this in the
West now to a certain extent in a
libertine world it's not about you just
hurting other people it's about if you
refuse to celebrate sin then you become
the bad guy right that is what was
happening then that is what is happening
to a certain extent now if you don't
celebrate sin and engage in sin and
Shearson then that's because you're
intolerant and you're bad and you have
to be sort of roped into the hedonistic
good time or you are the killjoy okay so
that is institution number one it fails
that society fails and brings upon
brings upon the earth to flood okay then
there's the second institution which is
what is saved from the flood and that is
the institution a family right that is
Noah and his immediate family so God in
in the Bible here eliminates all of the
social institutions except for the
family so God says you shall enter the
ark you your sons your wife and your
sons wives with you and from all that
lives of all flesh two of each ie bring
into the ark to keep alive with you they
shall be male and female so the purpose
of building the ark is to keep the
family alive it's to be holy within the
confines of your own of your own domain
okay so that is institution number two
so you have three ways of viewing the
world one is a family based way of
viewing the world one is an individual
way of viewing the world that doesn't
care about anybody else and then finally
you have the other extreme which is the
communal based way the communitarian way
of viewing the world where the
individual doesn't matter the only thing
that matters is the collective so we've
had the individual is the only thing
that matters not the collective then
you've got the collective matters but
not the individual then you've got the
family which is the proper merger of how
society is supposed to be formed based
on these these small these small phalanx
of people who are individual have the
individual interest but exist within a
communal sphere the the sort of
communitarian way of viewing the world
is told by the Tower of
so the the Tower of Babel story is
really puzzling because what's wrong
with munch people getting together and
building up a tower likewise God so
ticked off what exactly is the problem
here
well according to the Torah the whole
earth is of one language and a common
purpose they said to one another come
let us make bricks and burn them in fire
and the bricks served as stone and the
lime served them as mortar and they said
come let us build a city and a tower
with its top in the heavens and let us
make a name for ourselves lest we be
dispersed across the whole earth so god
promptly disperses them so people read
this as they were building a tower to
challenge God okay that's actually not
in the text of the Bible it doesn't say
that they were like on top of the tower
with a spear like throwing the spear at
the clouds or something that's not what
was going on what happens here is that
the community starts to value itself
more than it values any individual so
there's something in the Jewish in
Jewish comment area called the Midrash
the Midrash is basically kind of
expounding on the stories and and adding
to the stories in ways that explain the
story usually metaphorically according
to the Midrash the Tower of Babel
becomes so tall and so grand it
supposedly took a year to shuttle bricks
from the bottom of the tower to the top
right which of course is an exaggeration
but the idea is that this is this grand
magnificent project and this is the key
part of the Midrash people mourned when
a brick fell and broke because a year of
work had been lost but when somebody
died there was no mourning they just put
them right into the wall right they just
walled them right in and they used it as
part of the building of the tower the
idea is that human beings individuals
mattered a lot less than the collective
project so God sees this and he says
this is a mistake humanity is not
supposed to do this right humanity is
supposed to recognize the value of the
individual so God says behold they are
one people with one language for all and
this they begin to do and now should it
not be withheld from them all they
proposed to do so he's not shocked at
them building a tower to challenge him
he's got it I didn't care what he is
shocked by is what these people are
doing to themselves he has made them
individuals he's breathed life into them
as individuals he has made them in the
image of God and they are promptly
subsuming that for the building of the
greater good so what this portion of the
Bible is really talking about is what
sort of society is the best society to
build the society that's built on the
individual alone without reference to
the collective the society built on the
collective alone without focusing on the
individual or the society that is built
on family structure recognizing that you
value the people who are closest to you
the most but also that you're an
individual who has to work within that
family structure and that families have
to learn to live
with each other in a broader collective
while still maintaining their value as
families right it's the the very
libertine the very libertine movement
the hedonistic movement hates family
right they want to destroy the
institution family they consider a
patriarchal they consider it to be an
imposition on your individual freedom
you've seen this attack and then on the
other side you've got the sort of
communist movement which says family is
also bad because family stands up to the
Communists projects which says that we
are all supposed to view each other the
same way that I would view my sister or
brother or kids or wife which of course
is nonsense that's that's not how human
society is is going to work the godly
society in the Bible takes the best of
both worlds right the individual society
lives for the present it doesn't live
for the future because eat and drink and
be married tomorrow we're dead the
communitarian project lives only for the
future because what we're doing now
doesn't matter our lives don't matter
all that matters is the grander project
the family project is about living for
the now and living for the future right
building a family around you that you
enjoy because you are also building for
the future as Solomon says enjoy life
with the wife you love through all the
fleeting days of your life has granted
you beneath the Sun all of your futile
existence for that is your compensation
in life and in your toil which you exert
beneath the Sun so that is that's the
covenant that god ends up making with
know is that he's preserving the earth
for families that is the goal to
preserve the earth for families ok so
that's a little bit of Bible talk for
you on a Friday we'll be back here a
little bit later today with two
additional hours otherwise we will be
here with all the updates for you on
Monday I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 on the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all the things that
are really important to you so come join
the conversation